[Music]
hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of entrepreneur tools
where I talk about all my favorite tools
resources apps that I use to run my
business today I'm going to talk about
Evernote and how I use it on my iPad as
well as on my computer and my laptop all
right so let's get started
Evernote is at its core a great way to
be able to share research and ideas
across all of your different computers
and devices as well as back everything
up online in case you need remote access
to it so I thought the best way to
actually show you how I use Evernote is
to use Evernote so I use Evernote on my
my office computer on my laptop at home
and on my iPad as well I'm going to
quickly cover how I use all three of
them so how I got started here in terms
of creating this video was I created a
file yesterday on my laptop called
Evernote video and when I got into the
office is automatically synced
automatically so I can come in and I'm
ready to shoot my video so today I
wanted to go over the intro which you
guys have already seen the three main
uses and I'm going to end with the
conclusion so the three main use is the
first thing that I use a for is receipts
and this is what got me started on ever
done I heard a lot of people talk about
Evernote and it looked interesting but I
couldn't really find a really good use
for it until I found out about the
receipts so I'm a big fan of having a
paperless office so I was trying to
figure out how to do it and Evernote
combined with a scanner called scansnap
allows you to scan in all of your
receipts and have them available online
for you through every note and also
through their online backup so you can
access it from any of your devices and
you can throw away your actual receipts
so a quick example if everyone allows
you to create different notebooks and
also have different files within them so
when the business receipts and this is
how I got started if I go back to last
quarter for example and if I type in so
these are all the different receipts
that I've had so this was a know lunch
or dinner at Boston Pizza as an example
I can quickly scroll through and see all
of my different receipts visa statements
whatever
I need that I can shred the actual files
I don't need to keep physical copies of
it if ever need to find something this
is a really cool part everything to find
a receipt instead of having to go
through all of my you know stocks of
shoeboxes or whatever it is I can just
go to Evernote and do a search and if
I'm looking for little Nicky's for
example I type in little and it shows me
that I spent whatever date this was
January 10th
I spent 56 dollars at little Nicky's so
if you ever need to find a receipt it's
so much easier to put it here now I've
also even done this for all of my
government documents and that was the
last thing that I want to let go of a
thought I have to have the government
documents just in case but I found out
that if you ever do need your government
documents at least in Canada you can
always get them resent to you hard
copies again if people won't accept the
digital copy so after that I realized
I'm just going to get rid of everything
go completely paperless and twice a year
I put together all of my information pop
it through scan snap and have everything
ready to go here in Evernote so if ever
need to find it receipt quickly I can do
it and it saves me a lot of time from
having to actually input them manually
so I flipped over to my iPad now and
another really cool thing that I love
about it is you can get all of your
files and receipts right here on your
iPad if you ever need it the best use
that I found for it is if you have to
make returns so as an example if I
bought something at the Home Depot and I
use this also for my personal reasons as
well not just for business
I can go search my notes and I could
type in Home Depot and say I bought
something that I wanted to return and
I've now thrown away the receipt because
I've scanned it in I can do a quick
search gonna look through all of my
different files looking for the words
Home Depot I didn't put it in quotes but
you can and say about something May 27th
this one's popping up here it will show
me the receipt I can click on it it'll
create a PDF and then here's my actual
receipt so I bought this from the
Toronto Home Depot cost you twenty two
dollars whatever it was that I bought
total twenty five dollars and the great
thing about this is I can
use this I could just bring my iPad and
because it has this scanner here the
barcode the scanner can pick it up and I
can make a return just from my iPad and
I've done this in a number of occasions
sometimes the retailers are not as
friendly about it but they are able to
scan it in and it's in their system the
alternative here is you can always find
the receipt at home and print it off and
bring in a physical copy of the receipt
from your printer but I've done this a
couple times just bringing this in and
they could scan the barcode in and you
can get your return so you don't have to
keep the receipts anymore okay so the
next thing on our list is creating
business notes and I found that when I'm
meeting people or traveling I like to
have my iPad handy because it's easy to
carry around with me and easy to take
notes on instead of having to carry
around the laptop or you don't have a
notepad and then have to transfer it
over to my computer so it's great to
have it on the on the iPad and I find
that whenever I'm doing meetings I'll
take notes and I'll create a new
Evernote note for so a quick example of
a meeting I have coming up I'll click on
this one here with Gretchen who's on my
marketing team Gretchen if you're
watching this video here's what's coming
up for our September meeting so I'll
just take some notes and and you may be
able to read some of the things that we
have on here you know adding articles
for our advice category famous
entrepreneur Twitter pictures may not
mean a lot to you guys watching but it's
our to-do items that that mean a lot to
myself and Gretchen and as I come up
with ideas I can always write them down
here and then they'll show up on my
office computer ready to have our
discussion so another great thing is if
I ever if we're having a meeting that I
have these items here again I can add to
them if I'm on my laptop or if I'm on my
computer and then as we have our meeting
I can also add items to it so I can
click on the note and I can click on the
little pencil here and you know them we
might come up with an action item like
write new blog post I could put that in
write new blog post and save I know
that's on my to-do items I also find
that I like doing it when I'm finding
different books or coming up with
different ideas I don't know about you
guys but I come with a lot of different
ideas when I'm traveling or not always
at my computer so I have an idea list
here
down here at the bottom I also have
things for books so I'm a research
different books that I want to read and
if I you know find something on my
computer I can always save it to this
file here and whenever I'm at the
library or bookstore I can refer to my
books to read and it's all here ready
for me to go so don't have to actually
remember what I wanted three now it
looks like I'm a little behind on my to
do on reading but Evernote will help
with that but will help me store all the
information at least that I need to
remember so I find that it's really
helpful for when I am mobile to take
notes and then when I am on my office or
my laptop computers I can quickly find
those notes and refer to them and follow
up on those action items so again I went
back to that file with Gretchen and just
added the right new blog post so now I
just switch quickly back over to my
desktop at the office here and if I go
and find that note with Gretchen
I'll find here that it says write new
blog post so it's been added and then I
can keep making changes and say ten more
and that'll save back to my iPad and so
whenever I'm traveling around or you
need your information or the different
ideas it's always very accessible and so
I find that when I especially when I
have in business meetings or if I want
to take a note and then have that
accessible to me quickly at the office
and have a running notes I used to do
this by email if I had an idea I send
myself an email but the emails start
getting a little bit out of control as
lots of ideas come in I'm sure
entrepreneurs can relate to that so I
found just sharing everything in
Evernote and having a file that's always
updated that I can access from any of my
devices to be extremely helpful
so there's a lot of different ways you
can use Evernote and we've talked about
how I use it for my receipts and how I
use it for my business notes and now I
want to talk about how I use it for my
travel it's a third most important thing
that I find amusant for and this is for
personal reasons but I find that when
I'm traveling I like to do a lot of
research on the places that I'm going to
we often like to do a lot of cruises and
so you only have a little bit amount of
time in each city
so we want to try to maximize what we
see and find things that are interesting
and help us get around so what I do
every time we're going traveling now is
I create a new stack in Evernote let me
find it here so vacation this is good
for personal or business use let's pull
one up so this is one that I'm working
on right now this is a trip we're doing
to California it's a cruise and what
I'll do here is create my agenda so this
is where we're going la San Francisco
all around California here and I'll
create a new note for every city that
we're going to and what I'll do then is
I'll I'll say we click on San Diego I'll
go to TripAdvisor and I'll pull out a
lot of the things that I find are really
interesting I think that you know myself
my wife and my son would enjoy on this
trip and I'll copy pasted in so I'll
have my description you know what it is
the ranking on TripAdvisor
the description the map of where we're
going and then that continues as we go
down the list so these are all different
things to do in San Diego if anybody's
watching this who loves San Diego let me
know or any any of a California let me
know what things I have to see but I
find it's really helpful so it's all in
one place
and then when I go to my iPad the maps
are super helpful because we can
actually go through and when I'm when
I'm in the actual city I can find my way
around and know what we're going to do
so typically I'll do all this research
either on my laptop or on my office
computer usually one of my laptop when
I'm at home pulling information that I
want to see and then I know that I'll
have that information readily accessible
when we actually go on a vacation I'm
not struggling researching kind of
last-minute carrying around a whole
bunch of guide books with me I've
already done the work it's on my
Evernote it's on my laptop and I can
just quickly browse through or if we're
having dinner I might pull out
I pad and we'll talk about the different
things we can do the next day so we'll
flip over to the iPad and I'll show you
what it looks like there and how you can
use that for your travels so we're back
on the iPad and I'm going to show you
what it looks like so when you're
planning your trip you can also do the
same thing so here's our San Diego file
and if I load it up you'll see it looks
basically the same as I had it on my
computer it'll show me the places I want
to go to they'll show me the description
to me the map and why I find it super
helpful is if I'm you know on the couch
chatting with my wife or we're having
dinner or whatever and I want to show
her all the different things that we've
researched and ideas for the trip it's a
lot easier to just pop up the iPad than
it is to pull up a laptop or go to the
computer so it looks exactly the same
the big benefit though is when I'm
actually in San Diego I can open up my
iPad and have direct access to all the
files and especially the maps so it
shows me exactly where I have to go to
get to the places I want to see so if I
want to go to Petco Park as an example
here and I know I'm in the East Village
I know you know here the streets I have
to take to get there and I'm not that
far away so I found that to be super
helpful sometimes if you're new in a
city it can be hard to get around on the
maps aren't very intuitive or user
friendly you're not quite sure of where
you want to go so I found this to be
super helpful and this is the main
reason why I upgraded my program so for
Evernote the regular package you get a
limit on how much you can upload per
month and I found it to be actually
quite generous and I never really
exceeded my limit but you can't get
offline access to your files through
your iPad and when you're traveling I
found that was really important you know
to be able to get at your files you have
to then go to a Starbucks or find some
kind of connection to be able to
download your files where I find
especially when traveling you need to
have it more readily accessible if
you're on the free program with Evernote
then you can get all your files in your
computer and your laptop you don't need
to be on the internet before your iPad
you need to be online people get your
files so that's why I upgraded the the
other upgraded price is five dollars a
month or $45 for the year so I thought
very reasonable people to get access to
my files whenever I want
thank you for joining me for another
edition of entrepreneur tools if you
guys like the video and you want to see
more please give it a thumbs up below
I'd also love to hear what you thought
about the videos we'll leave a comment
or if you have a question about Evernote
or share how you use Evernote or any
other apps or tools that you use I'd
love to hear about them if you want to
leave it in the comment section below so
thank you and I'll see you on the next
episode
[Music]
you
[Music]